six this is eight news
now dieters says the problem with the
unemployment site
is now continuing tonight the department
says they're still working on fixing it
joe moeller spoke to some really
frustrated claimants
he's live at the deter office with more
hey there joe
hey there brian both regular
unemployment claimants and pua claimants
say they are having
issues some say they cannot file their
weekly claims well dieter did release a
statement yesterday and again today
saying they are working on this problem
and they expect to have it
complete when it comes time to file for
next week's claims
you know all we're asking is to keep us
informed about
what is going on susan cape is one of
many who are unable to file for weekly
claims
monday dieters said they were looking
into the website problem well this is
what they said
staff are working to correct the issues
no define
no yeah no defined time frame
what kind of answer is that to give
people who are depending on this money
to pay their bills tuesday the
department said the agency is working
diligently to identify specific causes
and resolve the problem as quickly as
possible
currently it is expected the issue will
be resolved in time for next week's
claim filing
it's a waiting game and like i said i'm
one of the lucky ones i have family
that i can depend on dieter also says
people will get the payments they miss
the following following week
social media you could call in i called
in i followed all the prompts
and you're not gonna get anybody when
you call you get a call back bill
dickerson was having issues on the
portal too
he saw a post on facebook explaining you
can file on the phone and
now his claim has been processed give
him a call start out early in the
morning if you can
that's the best time between 8 and 10
where you leave a message
dickenson like many others online say
they did not know they could even
file through the phone line we put that
number on the screen the number he used
he says he might have just been lucky
because we know how many issues people
are having with those phone lines
now dieter also said they do know
there's an issue with the pua website
they're working with the vendor
to address that and get that working
once again reporting live outside the
data office joe mohler 8 news now